I would love to ask you about leadership
especially on the on the side of the
United
States what has um the current
Administration the Biden Administration
done different than the Trump
Administration as you understand uh that
may have contributed to the events we
saw this week so all I can talk about
are are where we left them right we left
them a place where they had tremendous
momentum in the Middle East uh I met
with them during the transition and said
you know look you know we even got the
um the Qatar Saudi conflict done which
was a big no piece between Israel and
Saudi would have been possible without
that so we even got that done uh in in
our lame duck period and um and they
came in and they said look we want to
focus on the three C's which is coid
climate change and China and I said
that's that's great but you know the
Middle East we have an amazing place
right now at stable there's momentum uh
Iran is is basically broke uh we put
such crippling sanctions on Iran that
they went from about I think it was 2.6
million barrels a day of oil they were
selling uh to um to about 100,000 under
Trump so their their foreign Cur foreign
currency reserves were basically
depleted and they were broke uh same
with the Palestinians we stopped the
funding to uh to to to the to to unra
the UN agency which is totally corrupt
it's it's you know we've put1 billion in
there over time I did a poll um in the
Middle East in uh Gaza to say okay we've
invested $10 billion here as a country
are we popular MH right uh the US had a
7% approval rating us Aid had a 70%
approval rating but it just felt like a
waste of our taxpayer dollars and again
we wanted to make it conditions based
the Biden Administration came in uh
number one uh they they they they
started insulting uh you know Saudi and
Russia oil prices went up at the same
time what they did was they stopped
domestic production of oil uh they made
it they disincentivized a lot of oil and
Shale uh uh production uh with
regulations they they stopped pipelines
oil prices went up um they stopped
enforcing the sanctions against Iran
probably to get the oil prices lower to
make up for what they were doing they
ran to Iran to try to make a deal uh
they started funding the Palestinians
again right away and I even said you
know if you're going to fund them if
that's your policy I I respect that
again elections have consequences and uh
you can take a different policy but what
I would recommend is get some conditions
make them do some reforms make them uh
give property rights to people make them
you know do real economic Investments
for people but they just went right away
so they were funding the Palestinians
not enforcing the sanctions uh and then
overall just projecting a lot of
weakness uh in the region so uh one of
the the most um embarrassing examples is
what happened in the United Arab
Emirates again an amazing probably one
of America's best allies uh over the
last you know 20 30 years uh they fought
with us in in Afghanistan they were the
first Muslim country to stand up and do
that after 911 because they didn't want
it to be a war of the West against um
against uh the Muslim uh Muslim religion
so they joined the fight because they
saw it as a fight between right and
wrong uh they have Rockets shot into
their country uh from from from uh from
uh from from the houthis and they
basically don't get a call from the US
for 17 days they need their equipment
that they buy from the US which greates
job in the US they need it restocked we
don't call so they've severely degraded
the trust that we had to rebuild with
our allies I think they've been working
now to get it back they after two years
started working with with Saudi and
Israel uh which I think was good you
know I think that they realized after uh
a stint that maybe the the process that
President Trump had created in the
region was the right policy and keep in
mind you know president Trump's policy
was uh that I was working on was very
strongly criticized uh during the first
three years before we're able to achieve
the results because it was departure
from the failed policies of the past and
so first there was Return To those
policies a peas Iran
um let's criticize Saudi Arabia then
they started embracing and working on
the Israel Saudi deal which I was was
was really exciting I think we were all
very excited about it um but they did it
in public and I think that that also was
something and I didn't have access to
their intelligence so I assumed that by
doing it so publicly they thought that
they'd either had to deal with Iran
because they were letting them get all
this Revenue where Iran wouldn't be a
problem but one of the reasons with the
Abraham Accords we kept it so quiet
during the whole time was because we
always felt like the troublemakers and
the region particularly Iran who we
thought would would be disadvantaged by
having uh UAE Saudi Israel altogether
Israel's uh nuclear power you have you
know other strong economies it Iran
seeks instability they seek looking to
create uh division in the region and if
you can create that economic sphere
where you have security from hia to
muskat from Israel to Oman all the way
through with Saudi Jordan UAE Qatar um
Egypt that's an incredibly powerful
block if you can make it secure and then
get economic integration that really
could be a Middle East that thrives so
Iran obviously wanted nothing to do with
that and that's why they've been working
to disrupt so I think the Administration
has they took an incredibly stable
situation with momentum I think they
underestimated um the uh the the way
that Iran would approach the region to
undermine I think they gave way too much
rope to Iran and I think that they
didn't see when they had an opportunity
of strength with the Palestinians to try
to drive to a conclusion that I believe
could have prevented uh us being where
we are today not to mention that you
know even just three weeks ago I mean
it's a bad look that they uh they just
you know basically gave $6 billion
dollar to Iran uh in exchange for
hostages and then Iran's basically
funding these Terror attacks are killing
American citizens you have uh in Israel
and um and it's just it's it's a
heartbreaking situation again totally
avoidable and one that I think has been
uh very badly mismanaged the
date